[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFFREY PURITT:
Morning everybody.
It's truly my pleasure to be
here today to briefly discuss
my favorite topic, my
TELUS International family,
as well as to share with you a
little bit about how Google has
helped to enable our success.
By a show of hands,
how many of you
has ever solved a Rubik's cube?
I thought it would be everybody
in this room, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe not Jim.
Did you know that the world
record for the fastest Rubik's
cube solve is 4.904
seconds and that it's
held by a 14-year-old
boy from Kentucky?
What I find most
fascinating about that,
no, not that he's from
Kentucky, but rather
the actual number
of permutations that
are possible-- 43 quintillion.
That's a 43 followed
by 18 zeroes.
And all based on
the decisions one
makes on how to twist and turn
the 54 elements of the cube.
42 years after its invention,
I believe this fascinating cube
is a great analogy for the
growth and success of TELUS
International.
As you just heard briefly in
[INAUDIBLE] kind introduction,
our company has
grown exponentially.
Since our inception in 2005,
starting with just 1500 team
members, one location in Manila
providing support in English
only, I'm proud to say
that 11 years later we have
what I believe to be the best
team in the business process
outsourcing industry.
Our 25,000 team members serve
some of the world's most
iconic brands across high tech,
retail, gaming, e-commerce,
health care, travel, finance,
and telecom from state
of the art facilities in North
America, Central America,
Europe, and Asia.
Our recent $1 billion
enterprise value
is predicated upon
our proven formula.
We carefully select and invest
in companies whose values
are aligned with ours, who
have teams that welcome
and celebrate
diversity, in leadership
that leads by example, and
in people who respect others.
While we've only made
three acquisitions, one
in each of Asia, Central
America, and Eastern Europe,
and each of those businesses had
fewer than 1,500 team members
at the time of our
original investment,
our real challenge
was harmonizing
these similar, but distinct,
corporate cultures.
Each of those teams took
a different approach
to recruitment and
on-boarding, to communication
and collaboration, to
performance management
and reporting.
Utilizing diverse operating
models, tool, systems,
and technologies to
ensure we realized
the requisite synergies from
acquiring and integrating
these disparate groups and to
support our aspirational growth
whilst consistently delivering
a best in class client and team
member experience, we needed
to think and act differently.
After all, according to the
literature, 70% of acquisitions
actually destroy
shareholder value.
So my story isn't about where
TELUS International is today,
it's about how we
arrived here, how
we overcame these challenges,
and most importantly,
how we plan to execute
upon our ambitious goal
to more than double the
size of our business
in the next five years or less.
And this is where Google
and their incomparable suite
of business tools
come into play.
So let's imagine that
each one of the nine
squares on each side
of the Rubik's cube
represent a different
business function
that the teams and operations
in each of our delivery centers
brought to the table.
Functions like HR practices,
recruitment, training,
learning development, sales,
marketing, communications,
payroll reporting which all
culminated enabling our team
to execute upon more
than 175 million customer
interactions we manage annually
via voice chat, e-mail,
and social media.
The thought of how many
different tools, platforms,
processes, and how disconnected
we might be as an organization
was overwhelming.
Remember the 43
quintillion permutations
I mentioned earlier.
So we had to quickly and
effectively align our teams
on a global scale.
And we found the perfect partner
with which to do so in Google.
Deploying Google
Cloud based technology
enabled us to standardize
how we did business
across our entire enterprise
and, in the process,
helped us to collaborate
and innovate,
promoted agile thinking
and actually increased
our team member engagement.
So how, you may ask?
Well, we know that
our team members
are our greatest
competitive advantage, which
is why we've cultivated a
unique caring culture that's
driving industry leading
engagement, attrition
rates, and scores
that are better
than the competition
which, in turn, led
to better performance and
increased top line client
growth.
We call this the
Culture Value Chain.
And as confirmed by
Frost and Sullivan,
we can now directly correlate
our unique corporate culture
with our industry
leading performance.
So constant communication
and collaboration
amongst our team members
around the world is critical.
Historically, teams
attempting to collaborate
across time zones
would inevitably
encounter issues with
timeliness and version control
of documents.
Leveraging Google
Drive and Hangouts,
our teams easily edit
documents, presentations
simultaneously and in real-time.
They can quickly book
a video conference
from their desk inspiring
spirited teamwork
and continuous collaboration
and innovation.
Additionally, our move to add
thousands of Google Chrome
boxes to our limited number
of Cisco TelePresence units
has made video conferencing
more readily available
and approachable, enabling
us to cost effectively
gather our team members for
training sessions, recognition
events, customer meetings,
business reviews, and even
board meetings.
Also, by deploying Google
Chromebooks to our team leaders
on the floor in our
contact centers,
they now provide real time
feedback and on-the-spot
coaching to help their
team members grow
and succeed in their roles.
The ROI has been impressive with
near instantaneous improvements
in our clients' key metrics
and happier, more engaged team
members who recognize
our investment
in their professional
development
and they stay with us longer
to grow their careers.
Finally, our pace of growth
makes business intelligence
even more critical to our
decision making process.
Leveraging Google
Scripts and Sheets,
we developed and
deployed a unique cloud
based BI platform
which, in real time,
aggregates operational
data from multiple sources
like ACD, time reporting,
CRM, and quality applications.
As a result, we now have
standardized operational
reporting across the globe that
provides deeper insights for us
and our clients.
Even with our over 100
clients and terabytes of data,
our front-line team members can
instantly assess performance
and take corrective action to
help us proactively deliver
on our customers first promise.
So as you can see, our
partnership with Google
has enabled us to
essentially speak
the same language in
so many different ways
which is, I think, all the more
a remarkable accomplishment
given that our agents
speak over 35 of them
on a daily basis
with our customers.
And we're only just
getting started
as we've just got two new pilot
programs underway leveraging
the power of Google's
Machine Learning capabilities
to take a revolutionary
approach to real-time fraud
identification and PCI support
as well as contact reduction
and automation.
When we're aligned as a
team and as an organization,
we have the white
space we need to be
agile and innovative to
focus on growing our business
and creating value for our
clients and importantly,
to do what is at the heart
of our caring culture,
to give back to the
citizens and communities
where our team members live,
work, and raise their families.
Well, I'm so very, very proud
of what our team has already
accomplished in working
to make the world a better
place, having
contributed $336 million
to charitable and
not-for-profit organizations
and, more importantly,
provided almost seven
million hours of
volunteer service
to local communities building
schools and homes, for example.
There is still so much
more that needs to be done.
I could not be more
excited by what's
ahead for TELUS
International and with Google
by our side as our trusted
technology partner,
I have no doubt we will achieve
our ambitious growth targets.
It may, perhaps, take
just a little bit more
than the 4.9 seconds, however.
Thank you all for your
time and attention today.
I welcome the opportunity to
answer your questions, if any,
during the break.
[APPLAUSE]